if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
look at that
all right well i don't know some kind of
problem with the intro audio for a
second i thought the problem was uh my
computer
but
it's actually all working fine it's
weird i played a little bit of this clip
and we can hear it fine so it seems to
be something with the uh something with
the intros i don't know i guess we'll
have to forego them today which is sad
uh but i am here i am here now many of
you are wondering what is going on today
um and you wouldn't be wrong to wonder
because we've been promoting
this um
uh live viewer town hall
for 6 p.m eastern on the east coast
today
and it's only going to be on the pacman
live youtube channel now of course i'm
live right now on our main channel as
well as on twitch as well as on facebook
so what's going on this is just a hype
stream to get everybody ready for the
pacman live stream in an hour and
hopefully many of you
will carry over and then we're going to
do this great town hall everybody's
going to be able to call in members do
get priority i want to be very very
honest about that
um
and hold on a second what else do we
have here
uh i think we're we're mostly okay
weird why isn't there ah there we go
there's twitch subscribers just getting
everything set back up okay yeah so in
any case everybody's we're doing a open
phones via discord davidpakman.com via
davidpakman.com discord at 6 pm east
today
everybody will be allowed to call in
we're just going to take calls
and if you're a website member you're
going to get priority we've established
on
the discord a sort of like um
separate voice channel
on which the members will be able to say
hey david i want to talk to you and they
will get priority it's going to be
amazing it's going to be amazing but we
have so many things to go over uh
between now and then including i have a
tucker carlson clip i've got deep fakes
i've got voicemails i've got so many
different things
um people already asking about another
town hall
we're doing one today
we haven't even done it's
let's partici let's see how today goes
uh although
i would be willing to say i would commit
to a second town hall next week
if we get a hundred website members
today
then i would do another town hall
and uh it's it's just gonna be really
really wild
okay where to start
so many different things going on
many people oh hold on a second before
we even go further thanks to our viewer
via twitch small fuzzy moss
i have a bunch of new audio drops a
couple of new biden ones
and corn pop was a bad dude right
i got hairy legs yep
and by the way maybe you could inject
some bleach in your arm and that would
take care of it oh wait a second and by
the way maybe you could inject some
bleach in your arm and that would take
care of that's a duplicate let me remove
that one
okay and then i've got one more
windmills do not cause cancer right
right so i've got those new ones
i have a couple of new
trump ones that people
might like
routers
we want the routers sonny
wendy we got to get those routers please
routers those routers those routers
we're so beyond the routers
those routers
they don't want to give up the routers
right so there's the router related
material and then maybe my favorite
trump clips of all time trump getting
derailed by feedback
and aren't credible oh these people
don't know what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
exactly
i think that's basically it as far as
new stuff cephei
sefer hide okay so we're caught up on
new drops which is very very good
i do want to say thank you
oh that's a good question will twitch
count today towards the possible second
member
or rather viewer town hall yes
um twisted hawk agnostic sister asf
clops nasty cues
junk saint pizza man
as well as jen here dave b
nug wrangler cosmos e lawrence c barker
all kicking us off today
putting us at 10.
today's recommended website discount
code is felony 21. it's such a good
discount code it should be illegal
that's it all right a few other super
chats to get to
um how do you change the mind of a guy
like joe manchin
i don't know that you do
i think you've just listen
i interviewed bill share on the podcast
today
he had a very interesting perspective
which was
without joe manchin you don't even have
a majority so like as frustrating as it
is to have to fight joe manchin over
infrastructure if that was a republican
then mitch mcconnell prevents this from
even being a discussion
and that's mathematically
incontrovertible right like there's no
way to deny that um
so i get we check out my interview today
with bill share because we talk a lot
about joe manchin and kirsten cinema
um pennsylvester says you've helped me
and my mom in so many ways thank you no
thank you
sir could you say hi to janiece and that
i love her yes
siobhani loves you janiece thank you
pepe says this is better than
rejuvenation i know it
i know what it it truly is it's really
something uh something remarkable
uh i'll try to stay awake here in
england thanks david yeah so if you're
just joining us at the top of the hour
we've got a live viewer town hall
exclusively on the pacman live youtube
channel we're trying to build up this
channel
100 new subscribers over there we will
be pinching off this stream at the top
of the hour and going over to pacman
live opening the phone lines wide open
and if you want priority
then absolutely sign up at
joinpakman.com because members will get
priority all right let's get into some
content all right this is just stuff
people have sent me over the last uh
week to 10 days that i want to go
through
um anti-massacre has a public meltdown
on a plane and threatens the flight
attendant this is really wacky stuff
let's take a look what happened on my
flight to l.a [ __ ] you talking to me
like that for me
i don't give a [ __ ] i didn't even want
to go to california
listen nobody's forcing the the
airline's not forcing you to fly to
california if you hate california so
much just don't buy the ticket
i didn't even want to go to california
the [ __ ] you talking to i will find your
name david
i will know your social security number
before i get off this plane on my
daughter
whoa
the same baby that you see me on on the
phone with
why why so what the [ __ ] yo yo watch the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] out what's the pain what they're
gonna do before what's the girl's gonna
do your mind to business
because i'll be man i have flights
coming up and i don't i really this is
the last thing i would ever want to be
dealing with on a planet come on
this guy's going to explain things to
other people yeah that makes sense
this guy's very clearly trying to
de-escalate in this the the shouter just
doesn't want to hear it
i'm trying to leave it
and i'm sitting here waiting
yeah so anyway really really wild stuff
happening on that plane here is another
one a dude in orange county melts down
after being kicked out for groping a
server
let's take a look at this one as well
is he not wearing shoes either
[ __ ] you
who the [ __ ] do you think you are what
do you think what the [ __ ] you think you
are is this guy miked up somehow the uh
it's amazing it's like he's speaking
into a professional uh microphone
[Applause]
[ __ ] you
i didn't count you right now give me a
job
screaming like that's actually really
bad for your vocal cords really really
bad like aside from complete and total
dysregulation clearly needs anger
management and all these different
things it's just unhealthy your you you
get all red
headache
uh it's it's like a uh it it really
raises your blood pressure and it's
terrible for your voice [ __ ] cops
please right now
[Applause]
please please give
[Music]
where's my card you threw it out of your
hand give me my card
[Applause]
he was very briefly de-escalated there
yeah
what man grab your card you just [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] weirdo you're the one who
dropped the chicken weirdo you grabbed a
chick's ass not him so who's the [ __ ]
ass did i grab
he also i guess is he drunk he sounds
sort of drunk okay so that's going on
there and it's all very very sad
um will i address the bitcoin all-time
high
yes
i had it ready to go right here in fact
because i do want to talk about it now
um what is the all-time high ever
64 863
so we're under a thousand dollars from
the all-time high
hold on a second let's see here
uh i am going to address bitcoin
momentarily i do want to say thanks to
guitar goddess for gifting five subs via
twitch also thanks to kane freddy bob
grim reaper mercolist
twisted hawk
all of whom have just signed up
putting us at 18 also a huge thank you
to joey kane for the website member
uh membership joey just signed up on my
website joinedpakman.com with the coupon
code felony21 is number 19 today but
thanks to being a website member joey
will get priority to talk to me at the
top of the hour when the live viewer
town hall starts today we're doing a
live viewer town hall on our second
youtube channel pacman live this stream
will go to the top of the hour it will
then end we will then go live on pacman
live and anybody who wants to call in
will be allowed to call in aloud like
you need my permission will be welcomed
um but website members will get priority
and you can sign up at joinpacman.com
also if we get to a hundred i will
commit to the heretofore unannounced
second viewer town hall next week
so there's a lot riding on this many
many different things
um
let's see here
stephanie says david can you give a
shout out to my sister eurydia
yes shout out
you doing anything if airplane scene
happens to you well what does it mean if
it happens to me like if i'm a passenger
and someone's losing their mind no you
though whenever i see in unstable people
i try to sit as still as possible
and blend into the background because i
this crazy thing happens where if i'm
like engaged listening when there's
someone going absolutely bananas
they'll they'll make eye contact with me
next thing i know their entire rant is
being addressed to me so this happens
sometimes when i'm walking out uh
walking around on the street or
different places when i see someone
disregulating i will just i i'm almost
like a uh
um
what what are animals what are animals
that have like a freeze response
when uh a predator comes by yeah i don't
know if it works with people i'm taking
this from the animal kingdom but
yes a rabbit exactly i'm like a rabbit
where like when i open up my my uh back
uh slider sliding door and there's a
rabbit in my yard eating all of my
vegetables it will just freeze i try to
do the same thing when someone's
dysregulating so while that would be
going on i would just be like this
perfectly perfectly still
and i would not make eye contact
obviously that would be terrible that's
what i would do
um okay
let's talk about
bitcoin bitcoin is
very close to an all-time high now as
many of you know
i have held bitcoin as the term may be
since the year 2015.
uh what do i think about this all-time
high i have no idea
uh today we had people saying it's going
to zero
going to zero
um and
we had people on cnbc today saying this
will be worth 250 000 a coin within a a
couple of years i don't pretend that any
of them know a damn thing i just have no
idea i have no idea
what i do think and i'm going to talk
about this on the show tomorrow so this
is like
uh
is is bitcoin used for criminality okay
well so was the u.s dollar and it's not
about that what about the energy
consumption what about the regulate not
about that my only issue that i'm going
to address tomorrow is
is it seeming likely that bitcoin is
just going to disappear go to zero and
nobody's ever going to talk about it
again no
um
naseem uh talib nasim nicholas talib
author of the black swan
um author of anti-fragile
author of you know various books
he when he talks about what should we be
reading he says you know if you really
want to read things that have stood the
test of time and that are likely to
maintain relevancy
look at what's been around for a long
time
if a book has been around for 500 years
and it's still in print and still being
read it's more likely it'll be around
another 500 years whereas if a book's
been around a year
it would be a little bit much to say
it's probable or even likely it would be
around 500 years if it's been around 10
years it'll probably be around another
10. bitcoin has now been around 12 years
and every year it becomes less likely in
my mind that this thing's just gonna
evaporate so do i know where the price
is gonna go i have no idea
do i personally hold roughly three to
four percent of my assets in
cryptocurrency i do that's my decision
it's not a recommendation for anybody
and what i've been doing is starting in
january
every time it goes up
uh to a new high
like if it goes up ten percent i'll sell
five percent
and then if it goes up another ten
percent i'll sell another 5
so over time i have fewer and fewer
coins but
um i'm sort of like locking in gains and
taking money off the table and and
shifting it to maintain that same asset
allocation that's what i'm doing
okay
not a recommendation for anybody if we
do hit an all-time high right again the
the all-time high is 64 863
we're right around 900 dollars per coin
shy of that today
uh we'll take a look keep me posted
all right
very good thanks to narwhal as well as
harry for the twitch subscriptions
number 20 and 21
also a huge thank you to three new
website subscribers grim reaper just
signed up at joinpakman.com
with the coupon code felony21
daniel hejnar just signed up on my
website with the coupon code felony21
and nathan blemeyers just signed up with
the coupon code felony21 we are doing a
live viewer town hall at the top of the
hour everybody will be welcome to call
in website members get priority today so
if you want to talk to me today signing
up at joinedpakman.com is a great place
to start and secondly if we fulfill our
goal of a hundred website members today
i will commit to a second town hall next
week in case not everybody gets on today
uh so a lot of different uh different
exciting things going on
uh okay a few other things i wanted to
look at here's something pretty nice
that someone made on the subreddit this
is a deep fake of me with producer pat i
guess is this like a chichen chang deep
fake i think that's what this is let's
take a look at it
oh hold on we need audio though
here we
[Music]
so
go
i've been smoking since i was born man i
could smoke anything man there's
producer pat there's me
i think you better light it in here man
what are these gas foods man
okay so very nicely done that's by
reddit user
independent nn i like it
here is one of my favorite new dave
rubin clips always pushing the
boundaries
really on the vanguard of big ideas and
here he defines occam's razor
well john let me give you another razor
occam's razor if something can go wrong
it will and that
basically was that if something can go
wrong it will that's occam's razor no
that's murphy's law
i think dave rubin actually
is um
that i think he's actually referring to
uh zeno's paradox as well as the
coriolis effect uh it's just becoming
completely humiliating at this point
it is completely
and totally humiliating let's look at it
once more and just the
the certainty and confidence
with which he says this
well john let me give you another razer
occam's razor if something can go wrong
it will and that basically is the
tagline basically administration let me
do two things for your producers right
now because i know you guys like to
fiddle with the chiron when i'm on can i
be called gen x expert or if they want
to be really pithy yes now i don't know
you know how on fox news
they've got their hard news
and then they've got opinion and if you
watch it you're like what the hell i
can't tell the difference it's hard news
and john roberts just said
vaccines are something weird so um
with dave rubin i can't tell if this is
a commentary segment or a comedy segment
because you know he was a uh he was anne
comedian at one point
and um there's this famous clip where
dave pulls the audience on their sexual
orientation it's a very very funny clip
and i can't tell if this is
a comedy appearance
on newsmax
or if this is a political commentary
appearance on newsmax i don't know
i don't know but it's all
very very strange
thanks to rgk
12
as well as agnostic
sister for the twitch subs putting us at
26.
very exciting
a folks asking when and how do you call
in to the viewer town hall okay let me
explain this one more time right now i'm
streaming on
youtube
twitch or twitch as some say and
facebooks
at 6 pm eastern which is in about 35
minutes
these streams will end and we're gonna
go live
on the david pakman show second channel
called pacman live you can find it at
youtube.com
pacmanlive
we will then be live on that channel and
the discord is gonna open wide open it's
gonna be like a whale's
mouth jaw something
uh and people will be able to start
dumping in calls
everybody will be welcome that's at 6 pm
eastern
um but if you want like almost certainty
to get on and talk to me we will be
giving priority to website members who
sign up at joinpacman.com so that's the
uh that's the thing that's the new hot
thing
to quote uh donald trump okay couple
other little things to go over here's a
tucker carlson deep fake where tucker is
honest uh this was i believe this was
another one of our viewers who put this
together this is i do want to warn
people this is pretty cursed
this is pretty cursed all right here we
go for once on this show
let's get real i am so full of [ __ ]
i lie
all the time anytime i'm in front of a
camera best believe i'm being a
propagandist for some of the worst
[ __ ] people on this planet true i'm a
[ __ ] prick the worst piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
do you know why i always make this face
for two reasons
one to mirror you idiots so you don't
feel alienated you bunch of babies
two because i have to look constipated
and confused to keep myself from
laughing
it's my game face oh man and even that
doesn't work half of the time
yes very very uh explosively honest
statements
from uh tucker carlson pretty amazing
stuff
and then here's a clip this just
happened earlier this is great the new
controversy
is that
the supply chain issues
shortages and possible christmas gift
uh delays
are being blamed on transportation
secretary pete budej being on paternity
leave now at its core the entire buddha
judge paternity leave thing has a whiff
of homophobia tucker carlson said a few
days ago oh pete buddha judge in the
midst of all this is on paternity leave
what learning how to breastfeed and of
course this is the homophobic trope of
gay men uh feminizing gay men and gay
men being like women etc etc so there's
a whiff of homophobia to the entire boot
edge edge thing and of course he's
entitled to paternity leave everybody
should have paternity to leave maternity
leave the entire thing he's also not
really on paternity leave because he's
been working
he's been on conference calls he's been
doing things all sorts of stuff so
now
everybody wants everybody on the right
wants to blame him now was everybody
blaming elaine chao
when there were shortages of toilet
paper pasta
canned goods
everything under trump no nobody even
knew who elaine chow was she was she's
mitch mcconnell's wife and was trump's
transportation secretary but now it's
pete but edge edge and this happened
today with gen saki and it's it's
pain it's delightfully cringe-worthy i
would say 65 of voters think that given
what's going on he should come back to
work
he's at work
he's on fraternity leave uh i was on a
conference call with him this morning
he's and he's in the department now
every day
listen emerald i think what you're
getting at here is this question about
whether uh men parents uh women should
have paternity and maternity leave and
the answer is absolutely yes in our view
that is the policy of this
administration that is what we're
pressing to all right anyway so you get
the point so that's emerald robinson
from newsmax
um trying to argue i guess that
it's because pete buddha judges on
paternity leave that all of this is
going on even though it's been going on
on off and on for some period of time
now there's a whole other like layer of
this to the stupidity
if in a country of 331 million people
gl uh nationwide supply chain issues
depend on one guy not being home with
his newborn twins
then we've got a really screwed up
system and obviously that doesn't pass
the sniff test and that's not the case
like every aspect of this is very very
dumb
uh but we're going to talk about that
more extensively on the program tomorrow
uh thank you to corey kimbrough
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
thanks corey for signing up your new
member number 27 today also big thank
you
to
scuba doodle
and libster tech for signing up via
twitch prime putting us at 29 we've got
about a half hour until today's live
viewer town hall starts over on the
pacman live youtube channel if you want
to be ready for that go to youtube.com
pacmanlive make sure you're subscribed
here this is where we will be streaming
uh the town hall at the top of the hour
everybody will get an opportunity to
call in which i think is just going to
be absolutely fantastic
also thank you to eagle bear morgan who
just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 30 today
signing up on the website not only gets
you priority on today's town hall but if
we get to a hundred i will do another
town hall next week which would be very
very exciting okay
uh let's see what else do we have here
via super chat
david i love your content it's really
important to be respectful to people
which you're great at hope to see you do
more debates in the future thank you
sir a commentator claimed you rug pulled
on the coin you promoted two times in
the past what happened or do you plead
the fifth i have never
ever ever
promoted the purchasing of any coin ever
and in fact every time i talk about
cryptocurrency i say i am not giving
financial advice
if you're curious as to what i'm doing i
will tell you
with endless caveats that i'm not giving
financial advice i am not telling anyone
to do anything the only the only advice
i give financially
what about a david pakman show
membership that's financial advice i can
stand behind that's something everybody
can feel very very good about but uh i
have never told anyone to buy any coin
currency
uh or anything any anything of the sort
tamisha asks a good question how will we
know who is a member during the live
stream excellent excellent tamisha
excellent question now you're really
thinking um
there's going to be two
um voice lobbies on our discord and in
fact i'm going to pull this up right now
and make sure everything's running as
predicted
we are going to have the regular
waiting lobby which is where you will go
on the discord if you want to chat with
me and you are not a member
if you are a member who has been
verified by the moderators on discord
there will be a separate
voice channel called
hoity toity exclusive hold on what's it
called
hoitytoity exclusive members now how do
you prove your membership you message
any of the moderators with a screenshot
of yourself logged in as a member on our
website that's it that they'll
immediately give you member status this
uh voice channel will only be visible
will only be visible
for those who are members now let me
just take a look at and see whether
everybody is uh
okay we've got a lot of people asking
for the website member role yeah message
the moderators are doing their best to
work through this we this is the first
time doing this we've got about 25
minutes until it starts
uh oh god no member waiting lobby i did
i give the wrong thing
oh my god forget everything i just said
i'm sorry let me back up
member waiting lobby is the voice
channel for our members
and waiting lobby is the voice channel
for non-members
okay so like right now
there's actually this is a great
opportunity actually to get on with me
and and get a membership there's only
four people waiting in the members
waiting lobby
um
very good okay all right so that's the
answer to misha i hope that it's not
more confusing um also there's people
starting to dm me
on discord don't don't dm me and if if
you send like a couple in a row i'm
gonna have to just block you it gets
overwhelming okay so do don't dm me
don't send me any private messages
on discord please please please please
okay thanks to uh and welcome to matthew
howell matthew just signed up on
joinedpakman.com with the coupon code
felony21 and his new member number 31.
let's do a couple of voicemails we i am
so so so behind on voicemails you guys
aren't going to believe this
but let's just
try
and see if we can start working through
a few of these um here we go
so i like noticed in society
that you could call any woman
[ __ ] thumb ugly [ __ ] okay and we're
done
i'm just realizing like some of the
benefits of like an expanded vocabulary
yes there are many here's uh eric from
mass
hey david uh
eric from mass again yep the conspiracy
guy uh
i just looking to do you you're
unraveling at the seams i'm looking on
the screen right now i'm unhinged guys
i've completely lost it
covered cases are up 300 next to one
that you put covered cases are down 20
yes the clips were from weeks apart
youtube may recommend things
thematically but those were from weeks
apart
so um i was just taking a look at
history um i'm just speculating so like
don't quote me or anything don't worry i
won't then back to eric from mass
hey david sarah from mass the conspiracy
theory got i mean conspiracy fact guy
then back to whitney
so um i wanted to communicate like some
things about just my experience and
dealing with
not dealing but um
my experience with
socializing okay then back to eric from
mass it's back to back they're both
calling all day and all night
hey david is there from mass this is
just a courtesy call it's a
courtesy call be like the young turks
and jump on the
uh voter fraud as
being uh debunked or discounted or
whatever because they're doing right now
on live tv and okay they should know
each other that would actually be
interesting
so um in society like um
when people are defining racism
like
if you think about it in terms of like
expectancy
um like if you're not a racist then
you're saying like then black people
should leave i feel like it's kind of
expectant black people should leave
weird
hey david it's uh eric from mass the
conspiracy fact guy
um i just wanted to let you know before
you
you know go on and on about
whatever the uh vaccine is about to get
pulled yep any day now by the way that
was from a month ago it still hasn't
been pulled
so i noticed on your show
that um
when you were talking about chris
christie you said that he should like
apologize i haven't mentioned chris
christie for a really really long time
yeah hey david i wanted to share this
with you uh
it's your conspiracy
guy again uh
okay then this other third regular
caller got involved
if you could do me a favor day a favor
david i have tried to call jesse on both
of his numbers and they disconnect from
me i don't know who that is what it was
telling me the universe is telling me
that
well i'm putting on pandora and if you
think pandora is named pandora for no
reason
no i'm opening the box for you [ __ ]
okay then back to whitney
hey
so
i was like reading up about like
post-traumatic stress disorder
then back to the other guy
well there's no way back from here
so i know people have been following me
they don't surveil very well
you can tell them too that fbi's
surveillance yep he's picked up the
surveillance on himself then back to
whitney
so um
i found like a pretty good analogy for
like really early time abortions
then back to the other guy
david you're number two technically
you're number three because i forgot i
had an orb which i have video evidence
of
i had an orb visit my friend's daughter
whose name is helena right then eric
from mass called back in
hey david um i just wanted to comment on
uh sarah from ask the teacher
that you had on it's got nothing to do
with research because i'll agree with
you i will agree with you on this if
that was a case that people came and
said i did research and yeah it is
arrogant you're absolutely right
that somebody would you know call in or
or tell people or go on the internet but
that's not what's going on okay all
right so that's that's basically my
voicemail line let me see if anybody
else called in during this period of
time
um
i don't know here's like a so-called
normal caller i don't know who this is
i do it i'm calling to
like
like kind of bring up a point that i've
been thinking about lately which is like
you know when i hear people say like oh
you can go see for yourself or go do
your own research or i've done my own
research i'm starting to
kind of see that as kind of a red flag
that
i mean half the time i feel like these
people don't even know what source
they're trying to cite yeah that's true
people saying they've done their
research you should see the research
they're doing so yeah no that that's
actually a good point i like that uh
thanks to chill sd for signing up via
twitch your new member number 32 today
live viewer town hall at the top of the
hour 19 minutes away
also want to say thank you to janet
geiger who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
thank you to dan becetta who just signed
up at joinpacman.com and kim baum just
signed up at joinpakman.com numbers 33
34 and 35
in about 15 minutes this stream will end
we will go over to the pacman live
youtube channel that's where today's
town hall will be taking place
um subscribe there and you can go to the
discord davidpakman.com
slash discord if you are not a member
you can
go into the regular waiting lobby
if you are a member you can go into the
members waiting lobby which is very
exciting very very exciting i see
tamisha's in there who asked about it
and
it's all very very good
uh brad says david sir you're oh i need
i actually need my sur material here
i don't even know where it is
uh oh here it is sir sir sir you can't
ask that question
sir he's better than i am i don't even
know what i'm doing sir
sir your wife is up in the air yes david
sir your subtle sense of humor is half
the reason i tune in keep up the great
work thanks brad i appreciate that
tag says david how many staff members do
you have to help you with your research
behind the scenes so i actually do all
the i research my own stories that's one
thing that i have not delegated i just
like see here's the thing
we've we've tried having different
people help me with the research but
what happens is when we split up
research on stories unless we talk about
every story
sometimes i won't remember something
someone else like the process i have
allows me to integrate everything that i
want to be aware of and that type of
thing so i found that that's actually a
good thing not to delegate not to
delegate
uh some people might not agree
but that's my perspective okay
let's look at um this is very very
interesting we've spoken before
about
um misinformation that runs rampant in
the latino community of which i am a
member this is an interesting little
vice news documentary
let's just take a look at it this was
sent to me i think it's we're not going
to watch the whole thing but let's just
take a look at it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
dear god it's already depressing
fernando arsei is making and selling
chlorine dioxide it's an industrial
bleach used to disinfect swimming pools
and floors dear god
is one of the many anti-vaxxers who's
convinced this chemical prevents and
cures covid by killing viruses oh man
just like it does on surfaces
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
couldn't this guy have the common
decency to just grow and sell pot
instead of this stuff
[Music]
the food and drug administration in
virtually every major health
organization in the world says ingesting
chlorine dioxide can be dangerous
and even deadly
but that isn't stopping our say he has
no medical training he's an engineer
[Music]
the rothschilds have indoctrinated us to
believe chlorine dioxide doesn't cure
hundreds of illnesses
is this
now okay so two questions does there
start to be an anti-semitic smell here
and is this guy even aware of it
right
a lot of times people don't even realize
that and some people in the oh wow a lot
of yeses already
that's interesting
um let's keep going
the use of chlorine dioxide has become
so normalized here that even some
doctors are embracing it oh my god dr
viviana figueroa uses the substance arse
makes and injects it into our patients
[Music]
oh it cures depression too wow this man
is fully vaxxed against covid along with
a quarter of bolivia's population
but figueroa believes the vaccine
introduces harmful metals to the body
she claims the course of chlorine
dioxide will detoxify him oh my god she
charges around 150 for a three-day
treatment
which she also recommends for patients
with severe covid
so it treats covid and depression i
guess
it is
i mean if you did have metal inside of
you because of the vaccine would you
want to rust the metal that doesn't even
pass the sniff test
[Music]
what a waste of time also
health organizations warn that drinking
and injecting chlorine dioxide can
damage organs there's no scientific
evidence it protects against or cures
cobit
amiga
wow this is even worse than i imagined
is
hi guys i'm here to demonstrate today
the spray protocol with chlorine dioxide
solution by the way
calling something a protocol makes it
sound more
legit but
it's just the word protocol
emergency enema i'm glad that so far
none of these folks are argentinian but
i'm sure that
the chlorine dioxide movement is huge in
latin america and everyone from
actresses to doctors promote it on
social media
it's often referred to as mms or miracle
mineral solution
[Music]
this isn't the first time bleach has
been touted as a miracle cure for years
people have been peddling it in africa
and latin america as a treatment for
malaria cancer and aids we have treated
more than 500
hiv cases promoters even targeted
parents of autistic children around the
world we have 38 children recovered in
less than 20 months of using mms to heal
cure and recover children from autism
this is even crazier
than uh you know
maybe you can maybe you can't i'm not a
doctor we're so beyond the whoops hold
on
donate plasma today please i see the
disinfectant is there a way we can do
something like that
uh by
injection inside or apply
light and heat to cure
when covet hit these promoters of
chlorine dioxide found a whole new
audience amongst people desperate to
survive the pandemic donald trump was
absolutely right when he said that a
disinfectant a non-toxic one can be used
to get rid of this horrible covet 19
pandemic that's andreas palker a
self-described biophysics researcher
from germany
from a florida company that has no
academic accreditation he popularized
chlorine dioxide as a coveted cure and
promotes it through paid seminars and
consultations
found the anti-vaxx group komosab at the
beginning of the pandemic
since then it's opened chapters in more
than 20 countries and spawn social media
accounts that have gained hundreds of
thousands of followers how is this
humanity guys how is this
the human race right now their greatest
victory is here in bolivia bleach was
already available on the black market
but last year lawmakers from the
country's left-wing government legalized
it as a coveted treatment oh my god
[Music]
now the country's military academy is at
the forefront of manufacturing and
selling chlorine dioxide products to the
public including chlorine dioxide
necklaces oh my gosh
[Music]
says
[Music]
folks things are not looking good
things are not looking good
see that's one of those things where
it's not a matter of opinion when i keep
saying
there's disagreements about what counts
as a fact
that's not a question of opinion it's
just let's just look and you see that
the schools where the kids wear masks
have fewer cases and a lower case rate
and you know it
[Music]
[Music]
i encourage people to check this out on
their own because it is really
really something else that is uh that is
some horrifying horrifying stuff
um
few other super chats that guy mixing
the chlorine dioxide looks really ill
yeah um
yeah he doesn't look great it's true i
mean it's not like this guy looks like
the pinnacle of health
uh fair point
um
lucian says sir why do you think there
are so many different standpoints on the
left but always only one radical one on
the right your moderate approach is rare
which is why i like your channel the
most you know that's not always true
like for example if you look at some
right wing conspiracies
there's all sorts of right wingers that
they come to the same conclusion but
using a different approach often
approaches that conflict uh you see that
with a lot of conspiracies flat earth
and others i don't think that that's
always true and and um
sometimes the left is united on a
particular issue i think that there's a
sort of um
a lot to take in with that i don't think
it's quite quite so simple i want to say
thank you to mz frazzled x brody x my
artist my art my art is my arsenal king
genito
and chill sd for subscribing via twitch
prime putting us at 40.
also thanks to katie musgrave who just
signed up on my website at
joinpakman.com
using a coupon code today's coupon code
is felony21 so here's the deal folks we
are four minutes away four minutes away
from the first live viewer town hall in
a long time i'm going to be taking all
sorts of questions from people
the stream this stream is going to end
and the town hall will stream
exclusively
on the pacman live youtube channel okay
so in about a minute
this stream will end
and we will start streaming on this
youtube channel youtube.com pacman live
if you want to talk to me
go on our discord davidpakman.com slash
discord
you can go into the waiting lobby
uh if you're a website member at
joinpakman.com
you can go into the member waiting lobby
very exciting okay priority given to
members everybody welcome all right so
we're gonna stop this stream now we're
gonna get set up the new stream starts
in three minutes
join pacman.com become a member if you
want to get priority we're going to be
talking to all sorts of people and if we
get to 100 website members i will commit
to another
uh town hall next week all right so this
stream now ends
pac-man live stream
starts in three minutes i'll see